winter is coming throw another body on
the fire the Queens Justice Game of
Thrones season 7 episode 3 yes I know
I'm a little late getting this out I had
a really busy weekend guys and there's
only so much I can do at once so I'm
looking to get back on track but first
there's a little bit of catch-up this is
the first thing this was really good in
my personal opinion best episode of the
season so far which actually means going
back to the first episode which I was a
little iffy on every single episode has
gotten better
that's a nice trajectory as always keep
in mind this is not spoiler free I'm
going to be talking about what goes on
pretty swiftly I'm also going to jump
around as stuff occurs to me so let's
start with Jon Snow meeting Daenerys I
didn't like how that started I was
really iffy on that but as it went on
and progressed and the way that they
kind of came to terms to each other by
the end of the episode I was good with
it basically I was really annoyed with
Daenerys early on because first of all
there's sort of the meta knowledge that
I know John is right and I want to like
Daenerys so for her to be an obstacle to
the guy I know his right makes me
immediately frustrated with her and
there is also the fact that just her
approach and I realized as the episode
was going on oh I get why she's like
this up to this point
she hasn't ever had to negotiate she's
just delivered ultimatums
she hasn't really been a leader Sami
she's led her people people follow but
she's been a conqueror she comes in and
just steamrolls whoever's there she's
not used to the minutia of having to
negotiate so thank goodness Tyrion was
there too I'm not going to say rein her
in he doesn't have that degree of
influence over her but to be a
mitigating voice and get everybody on
the same page Davos was also really good
for that he was great too and so even
though she frustrated me pretty much
from the word go as soon as she started
talking with John by the end I liked
that that was the starting place because
it gave basically their relationship and
coming to grips with each other became a
little mini arc within the episode if
they had dragged that out if she was
going to be an obstacle to John for more
than
an episode would have infuriated me they
didn't do that they kept into an episode
that works surge auras cure and I yeah
this is I'm not going to say it's a
sticking point in this episode this is a
potential sticky point for me later they
better think of something really good to
do with him and the reason I say that is
because I thought his exit was beautiful
and perfect and I remember thinking at
the time I kind of hope he doesn't come
back because there was something
beautifully poetically tragic about that
being the end because in my mind the way
it worked with he had this infection
that has no cure he's going off
basically to die she tells him I order
you to go and find a cure in my mind
that never meant oh now he'll go find a
cure that meant that what she gave to
him was purpose instead of just going
out to die he goes out with a quest he
will not complete that quest he will so
die but he will die with purpose and
purpose that she gave him I found real
wonderful melancholy tragic beauty in
that that now is no longer the case
because he's alive now I'm not going to
think this is a bad development cause
it's going to depend on how they pay it
off and what they do with him now so
we'll see I hope they don't botch it
because like I said right now his exit
was one of my favorite things when it
happened so don't ruin this for me guys
I'm crossing my fingers on that I really
like the dynamic between Jim Broadbent
and Sam and that Jim Broadbent is giving
him his dues he's giving him his the the
proper recognition for what he
accomplished but at the same times like
you still at the bottom of the rung dude
you got to work your way up I don't know
what else there is for Sam to do at this
point I just yeah he's kind of he's now
served to plot functions he got the
information to John he's now saved Jorah
they better find something else for him
to do otherwise the story doesn't need
him anymore which makes him very
expendable bran was a little weird this
episode not bad but he's he sort of
jumped into this odd detached thing
since he's taken over being the
three-eyed raven and it seems like a
little much I mean
I guess if I'm being fair at the same
time it wasn't totally clear how close
he was to Sansa in the first place and
obviously they both been through a lot
but he was just
oddly cold and I guess I'll be
interested to see if that's going
somewhere or if it was just an odd
character choice um
Sansa taking control in Winterfell
I'm liking she's smart she's paying
attention she's getting in there and
saying I see that this is wrong fix it I
like all of that and Littlefinger and I
I'm frustrated and irritated that he's
around in the best possible way because
I enjoy hating him so when I'm watching
him give her what is legitimately
helpful useful advice knowing that he's
ingratiate himself to get in better to
be able to get what he wants out of her
infuriates me but in a very um in a way
that I don't just like in a way is like
Oh Littlefinger so I
he's maddening but in a way I don't want
him to go away not yet that's a time I
really hope Sansa is able to if not
completely resist at least not just fall
under his sway and ultimately end up
doing whatever he wants her to do that I
would like to think she's got more
internal strength at this point and
she's showing enough strength as a
leader that I think he's going to be a
problem but I don't think he's just
going to turn her into a puppet and that
would take me off and I don't think it's
going to happen
we had the bit with Searcy and ilaria
and Knossos fine I I knew she was going
to take revenge in that scene and I got
real nervous as to how she was going to
do it especially like knowing that
they'd established that ilaria saw the
mountain I'm I got really afraid of how
brutal this was potentially going to get
and the show didn't go there and I'm
glad and seriously went for the more
poetic poison list I do find it
interesting that they didn't show the
actual death of the sand snake that
would
was left I don't know if there's just
kind of string that along or if that is
going to end up ultimately meaning
something but yeah that was harsh it was
a surprising kind of roller coaster
watching the Taking of Casterly Rock
watching the unsullied show up in like
oh they can't get through that and then
Tyrion revealing you know I know this I
know the way in it's like oh they will
and then pull and then them realizing
there should be more troops here pulling
back and there's your ons fleet
realizing what the Lannister what the
bulk of their army is actually doing
it's just you're like oh no oh yeah oh
no I
and it's just that's that's a fun
emotional rollercoaster to be taking on
just the highs and lows is you realize
how things are going down which then
brings us to Highgarden and Alayna
Tyrell going out like a boss I I've
loved this character from the instance
she showed up Diana Rigg has owned it in
this part so well and I just love that
she knows there's nothing she can do
about it but she takes the places she's
just gonna twist the knife on to Jamie
and just give him this little era you
could have had your revenge on the
person who was responsible for Joffrey's
death but it's too late because I'm
gonna have a nice Pleasant death nothing
you can do about it so there that that's
a Westeros mic drop if there ever was
one
I think that's pretty much it I think
I'm the other thing I want to touch on
and I think I've said this before I'm
surprised how much I like year on
Greyjoy because I didn't see the point
of him when he was introduced last
season I'm getting a you know the vibe
I'm getting from him is spike from Buffy
like season two spikes evil spike that
is the vibe I'm getting from him this
guy just loves what he does and it just
it just makes it all the more fun and
yeah this was a really good episode like
I said there's a couple of things that
have happened that aren't bad in and of
themselves but I'm kind of like crossing
my fingers that they are either not
going to go
down a certain Road they don't want them
to or are going to pay off well because
if they don't then I might retro
actively end up having issues but for
the episode in and of itself love it
great stuff so those are my thoughts on
the Queen's justice did you see it I
hope so I spoiled it what are your
thoughts on it whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give it a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher I am also one half
of the punch like a girl podcast also
available on iTunes and stitcher until
next time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]